cassette avec talent la casca ça
castagne wa wa wa kalenga style à
chaillot je pense à un truc ya un truc
qui grave
il ne faut jamais se bagarrer non c'est
vrai se bagarrer pas bien bon mais
est-ce qu ici autour de la cam y en a
déjà qui sont embrouillés par les mecs
des buy com a tu vois je sépare tient
pas en cacahuètes en genre en voiture à
bas uci tories non mais t'es tu connais
ou pas ce que je sais moi c'est quand
arrive c'est en voiture comme ça tu vois
tu fais le beau quand tu es dans ta
voiture tu as la pression tu peux tomber
avec tout le monde est monde mais ce que
je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
c'est à dire que quand vous il ya une
petite voiture tu as l'impression que ça
va être un petit gars qui va sortir
donc tu te dis je m'en fous je
m'embrouille avec lui je vais le
défoncer et quand tu vois un énorme
canon tue non franchement sadr est un
petit gars qui sort d'un camion j'en
rigolais la veille tu peux avoir aussi
un espèce de youssef mon pote qui sort
bylsma
là-bas la fin j'ai vu youssef ans marc
ducrocq qu'il est en roller là il
dépassé le gaza un truc de fou je vous
dire c'est vrai non mais ça veut rien
dire tu vois il ya des gars tout petit
enfin j'ai vu passe partout il est en
smart j'ai cru qu'il est tombé 5 cm
attendait d'ailleurs jean barbon
bouillir donc ça c'est malin c'est pas
la voiture qui fait la force du gars
derrière l'as déjà en bouillie ouais
voilà quelque part voilà genre une
embrouille avec un mec non j'ai pas ou
bien dans là que tu sais dans l'accueil
la boulangerie ça c'est toujours un
ouais ouais bah castaldi avant oui avant
je cherchais moi je lance ici qu'elle
s'est passé raconté le winston adore les
lecteurs moi j'adorais bagheri en fait
alors oui je me faisais souvent castany
un g2 non mais attends dans nos îles à
niveau et une fois que john magaro ya en
effet dans un bar ya un petit un petit
mec mais vraiment impressionnant qui
arrivait je vois évidemment je les ai je
des chambres et pourquoi parce que
j'évolue de chambrée corps un peu comme
vous voyez le genre je cherchais un peu
la merde quoi
comme on fait avec moi voilà avec moi
pour savoir que tu es cherchons c'est
vous qui me chercher non ces mots thank
you c'est moi qui ai franchement ils
paient pas de militer tout rabougri
devenu est vraiment soulagée en faire
qu'une bouchée et s'approche de moi mais
genre hyper sûr de lui et je dis quand
même et l'une est gonflé et dit je vais
être sympa avec toi je vais enlever mon
voka saint il avait un mocassin comme ça
il a fait comme ça le temps qu'ils
enlèvent le magasin et m'a mis un mois
va figurer dans la tête
la ccb directs indirects et après donc
il est attendu je me reprenne des
esprits m'a dit tu vois dans la vie il
faut toujours se méfier le petit n'est
pas forcément celui qu'on croit
non bah je vais garder en mémoire sa wii
jamais je me suis attaqué un petit même
un grand d'ailleurs casotto énorme
j'étais chez le coloriste à base d'eau
et espèce de châtains foncés
et blond cendré wattez câbles ont semblé
alors il embraye que le risque non alors
j'étais au collège j'étais deux ans
j'avais 12 ans donc j'étais devant le
collège me suis fait défoncer par cinq
mecs je perds parfois c'est quand ils
nous tapent il n'arrêtait pas dire haut
et steven steven simone et c est après
tout les jours steven berline jamais
changé c'est pas moi steven en fait il
voulait défoncer à d'autres mais qui
vont dépenser moi j'ai rien fait et
steven on n'a jamais rien on n'a pas eu
de ses nouvelles
ils se sont pris pour excuser après bari
sont bas quand c'est vrai que ça va ça
fout montiel le bagarre alors moi j'ai
un truc très con c'est comme d'habitude
c'est que il ya quelqu'un devant moi qui
m'emmerde et en voiture si vous voulez
alors il est sorti évidemment il manque
de pot il était très grande donc moi
qu'est ce que je fais je sais c'est déjà
une matraque télescopique ses intérêts
je sais alors elle ça j'essayais de
l'ouvrir comme ça ggp était mort et pour
coulisses
il a tellement ri le mec qui m'a laissé
tomber de colère je sors de la bagnole
c'est pas très costaud donc bon tant
qu'à faire je j'utilise des choses donc
je sens la vanne traque télescopique
savez quand les séries cela alors je
fais comme ça tu sais pour la sortir par
gpt le rétro je peux vous donner un
conseil
oui ça madame au contraire quand on sait
pas son service prend dans la gueule
jeremy dear je vous le dis ah oui eh ben
oui ça oui
gilles verdez alors moi ce que je fais
c'est que quand je traverse les passages
cloutés je ne supporte pas que les
voitures ne s'arrête pas je ne regarde
pas aller voir les mecs comme ça
ah oui qu'on semble endormi avec la base
temps après la voiture est à ma hauteur
ce que je fais c'est que je tape sur le
carroi mais ça ou alors il ya un combat
qui est comme ça bon tu fis sur
l'histoire et moi j'ai un jeu alors
faites le avec vos potes c'est que quand
je suis avec des potes en voiture je
monte à l'arrière et joue la vitre
arrière et je tape comme ça tu sais
qu'il va tout me dit toujours ne fait
jamais ça parce que tu vas faire casser
la gueule par un mec d'accord et il ya
quelques semaines je fais ça tout le
temps je tape au carreau arrière le
maître filmer directement à paris sur
boulevard sébastopol le mec il s'arrête
normal à ce moment là je dis je le dis
ouais ta gueule tout ça le mec sort il
va mieux
tu pourrais être mon grand père je vais
te casser la gueule et le mec super
menaçant etc j'ai cru que ma dernière
heure était arrivée
et là j'ai réussi à garder mon calme et
je lui ai dit je vous parle comme un bon
petit fils calmez-vous jeune homme est
le mec qui s'est calmée littéralement ah
ouais c'est beau c'est quelqu'un vous
avez dit cyril je vous parle comme à mon
petit-fils qui s'accroît et la démarche
agile mais moi moi jamais mais moi je
suis pas vraiment je peux vous dire que
ça non mais je voudrais dit qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
est ce que c'est une solution nicolas au
moins il m'arrivait il m'arrivait
souvent genre d'histoire mais j'ai eu il
n'y a pas très longtemps quelqu'un qui
commence à me coincer dans une dans un
truc où il y avait pas deux passages
pour de voiture et j'ai commencé avec
l'actionnaire m'énerve et je voyais pas
très bien et un mort né dis [ __ ]
pardon puisque je commence à m'énerver
en aidant la personne tu commences à me
saouler vas-y garde toi machin tout le
truc est un moment donné il ya une nana
sublimissime qui sort de la voiture et
là j'étais commun en fait au lieu de
continuer mon truc j'ai été bon je suis
vraiment désolé je vous prie d'excuser
jamais rien
les gens avec des battes comme un conte
et du coup j'ai un peu arrêtez de arrivé
une ou deux sera sera quand même assez
hard qui ont été surtout un jour ou
l'autre je nai tania young qui était sur
la météo de france 2 mai à paris j'ai
quelqu'un qui m'a confondu comme ça et
qui m'a mis un flingue sur la tête en
plein paris je rigole pas et c'est un
fou furieux en fait le mec et personne
n'a osé bouger pensant qu'il s'agissait
d'une histoire vraie et même tania gsm
il parlait demi mots en disant fais
quelque chose quoi de machin le mec
était complètement taré et elle pensait
que j'étais vraiment dans une histoire
un peu bizarre le mec qui arrêtait pas
de me dire ou es reculer c'est toi qui
m'as sa cause de toi je me suis retrouvé
en taule machin truc alors érigé à tenir
mais tu te fous de ma gueule ou quoi
mais tu as cru vraiment j'étais dans une
histoire dont ces cas là il ya eu un
truc à dire si c'est pas moi c'est
castaldi c'est vous dire mais c'était
surprenant parce que la manson a fait le
job ses terres que le restaurateur il a
flippé il s'est enfermé dans son truc
j'ai fini par par arriver à faire venir
la police qui est arrivée qui a été
chercher le mec qui soit rival choper en
fait le mec m'avait confondue avec
quelqu'un mais j'ai passé les dix
minutes les plus longues de mélèze de
procureur c'est pourquoi l'un des deux
procureurs ses concurrents mais pas les
filles l'acte i ou pas vous avez saison
il ya des embrouilles à saison à l'école
attention et moi je me rappelle en
primaire
une connerie un truc vraiment bidon on
joue aux barbies et moi je voulais la
barbie ultra stylée et on la voulait
toutes les deux et en fait je les mordu
jusqu'au sang
barbie oui batailleur elfin toinon soi
mais moi c'est pas forcément en voiture
c'est donc vous le savez mon chéri à une
discothèque est en fait à chaque fois
qu'il ya des embrouilles dans la
discothèque j'adore je cours et je vais
au milieu d'une e tu vois du new south à
cassel et en fait quand je me mets comme
ça au milieu cheyrou assez bon et tout
et les mecs sont tellement surpris de
voir une nana au mieux et en fait ils
arrêtent naturellement j'ai déjà pris
cette rencontre c'est normal on voit des
fines arrivée on a plutôt la couleur dit
c'est très chaud cette année la gueule
c'est un avion qui vient d'arriver au
scope toi vous avez elle a été lente à
la volée le rideau
on rigole c'est magnifique c'est magali
bertin si vous la connaissez pas bien
sûr magani verna spécialiste bien sûr
intérêt bien sûr politiques et chirurgie
est stricte et conneries oui alors moi
c'est vrai je vous jure c'est une
histoire de rire j'étais dans mon van et
là d'un coup le gone oui enfin là
j'étais dans un van
vous avez un va mieux mais c'est vrai
que c'est moi qui lui ai vendu et ont
bien fait le vôtre je suis dans le van
et là d'un coup le vanni pile comme ça
j'ai dit mais c'est qui ce camp et je
vois en vélo passé comme ça m'a changé
c'était qui s'était cyril hanouna
bien sûr les chefs à indy celle ci
relève la fermeté un nom c'est vrai et
alors que j'étais à vélo en vélo vous
avez un petit poisson comme ça mais des
tentes ont ils été enlevés le tout seul
détendu comme ça et regarder papou boom
boom mais je suis désolé on ne sait pas
quelle excuse non magali quelques unique
et ouverte la république de metz avec
les cas de chirurgie esthétique je
reconnais qu'à 3 heures du matin je suis
un niveau tu sais moi j'ai un jour là
samedi matin ben oui oui j'ai demandé
une liposuccion la semaine je peux pas
je n'avais pas le temps s'il vous plaît
pour aimer les films en fait la culture
c'est quoi le tout le corps tout le
corps après je fais tout ce pharaon fait
la totale ça ça m'a d'accord elle
s'enraye gilles foussat de valérie
benaïm salle éric et moi je suis pas
très bagarre non mais mais en revanche
n'ont en revanche moi je suis
étonnamment pas pas à pas et nos vols en
a c'est vrai alors là vraiment je peux
dire des noms d'oiseaux ont fusé comme
isabelle morini bosc
elle est insupportable au boulot oui
mais comme cela et donc moi je me voilà
donc moi et je pars du principe qu
effectivement si la personne sort de sa
voiture elle va voir que c'est une femme
et et peut-être qu'elle viendra pas me
casser la gueule donc non mais bon je
l'aï jamais eu de gros problèmes non
j'avais le gros gros gros gros problème
ouais moi je vous ai raconté mon
histoire qui m'est arrivé non non je
veux tant qu'elles accueillent
elle est très longue il est incroyable
c'est quoi quand vous connaissez pas
l'histoire
ah ben non à quelle est l'histoire
incroyable je vous racontais liste je
suis un jour je suis je vois les étangs
de la dombes et l'histoire elle est
folle je suis dans mon bureau et il ya
la sécurité de ses victimes à peine et
qui me dit il ya quatre personnes qui
sont venues dans une voiture et qui vous
cherche tous d'accord et je dis comment
il était et tout ça va il ya un autre
endroit un café où je vais un mec qui
m'appelle il dit en avoir il ya deux
gars qui sont venus qu'ils cherchent
oulala bongo la nuit ils ont pas l'air
très sympa tout ça bon j'appelle ces
vigies kechiche appelle l'agent de
sécurité de ses 8 qui était devant la
porte
je suis dit comment comment ça s'est
passé est oublié les mecs étaient un
petit peu
ils étaient quatre dans une voiture y en
a un qui est sorti qu'est venu qui m'a
dit ce qu'il est à cyril hanouna mais un
peu menaçants jadeyaoui garay genies que
tu peux m'envoyer les caméras de
surveillance donc je regarde les caméras
de surveillance je reste devant pour
mort en mai genre une heure et demie je
vois les allers retours
on a avec diego mon pote c'est qu on
regarde aller retour on voit une audi
qui s'arrêtent un mec qui pose un truc
sur le sur le siège qui sort qui
arrivent ils à une capuche
il a des lunettes même menaçant quand
même il dit les ou cyril hanouna bon
vous dire on passe à autre chose
ouais là l'après-midi pareil y
reviennent c'est bon c'est pas possible
et tous les mecs me cherche et c'est
donc là je dis bon j'arrive à avoir le
numéro avec le numéro de la plaque avec
la voiture et je demande pendant qu'on
est dans l'émission parce que tout ça se
passe et je suis pendant l'émission et
jeudi nega trouver à qui appartient
cette voiture on sa joie là et là il me
dit voilà on a un look a apparemment
c'est des mecs qui sont venus de lille
ou tourcoing et qu'ils cherchent
alors moi dans ma tête là je pars dans
un délire je dis ouais c'est sûr c'est
des mecs qui veulent me faire péter
je suis pas bien on rentre chacun chez
soi 3h du mat
c'est une vraie histoire j'appelle le
diego jeudi réunit mois une équipe on
part tout de suite à trois histoires
vraies paiement l'un des gros c'est une
histoire vraie un mini histoire vraie il
dit n'a pas eu le réveil tout le monde
mais non on part avec youssef adnane par
vous vous dites pas ça
j'ai déjà parce qu'en fait je lui ai dit
écoute moi je préfère attaquer sur
rigoler qu'on soit en position
d'attaquant ah oui le taux que c'est un
peut arriver n'importe où ouais parce
qu'en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
c'est ça je vous prie de vous dire c'est
que pendant l'émission j'en voyais des
gars tourcoing deux autres gars moi à
tourcoing pour voir et pour repérer ils
disent ça y est on a repéré la voiture
ils ont trouvé la voiture etc jouent dur
que c'est nice port des minimes on a
repéré la voiture on sait wade pss donc
j à diego on va maintenant demander où
est cette voiture ce qu'ils avaient
l'adresse du mec avec la plaque et où
ai-je dit on y va on par tourcoing c'est
trois heures du matin on arrive à 4h30
4,50 vraiment on arrive on arrive à
tourcoing et là où va à l'endroit où il
ya la voiture de qui est plein de
voitures c'était un parking avec voilà
des immeubles etc et on voit la voiture
ouverte est allumé voilà mais c'est quoi
cette histoire là on se dit bon les mecs
vous repartirez vous revenir sur paris
docteur péter moi la personne descend on
regarde dans la voiture il est plein de
sandwiches par tous genres on voit que
les mecs étaient restés dans la voiture
pendant toute la journée
il est 5 heures du matin jeudi
c'est peut-être mieux on va quand même
allé au commissariat de tourcoing pour
les prévenir
bah oui comment j'arrive 5 heures du
matin je sonne aux connaissances
pourquoi
[Rires]
hanouna qui tu fais là puis bon je suis
qu'à faire le mec me dis ouais un truc
un peu bizarre votre histoire tout ça
neil bon attendez là normalement la
droit de rien faire
mais attendez là et là il ya deux mecs
de la bac qui descendent fois au cirad
bas que tu fais là je leur explique
qu'ils font bon vas-y douce et on va
quand même aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil les mecs vont jeter un coup
d'oeil et il arrivait tout là bas il
voit la voiture allumé sahinidis bon ils
reviennent et on a vu la voiture
allumées et où mais je pense que moi
j'avais j'avais ramené les caméras de
surveillance avaient filmé caméra turin
cindy c'est pas la même voiture
donc à mon avis c'est ce qu'on appelle
une doublette qui achètent les deux
mêmes voitures émettent les mêmes et la
clé même temps mais manny mania bon et
me disent ça sent pas bon ça sent pas
bon
moi dans ma tête payet qui est bon c'est
sûr on veut nous faire péter on part du
commissariat et d'un destin non mais
l'histoire est d'avis sort du
commissariat
et je dis à mes gars réunion il est 6h30
jeudi les mecs on a une heure et demie
pour repérer la part tous égards et à 8
ans on intervient c'est pas une balle
non mais les vrais la télé c'était un
film non interview intervient comme ça
ou alors j'ai dit on intervient 8 heures
du matin cet été est survenu dans le van
on est devant l'immeuble
on attend évidemment la voiture on
repère chez dc à 8 heures ils sont pas
sortis on intervient avant on y va ah
ouais et un toit bien j'ai eu mme bryce
thouars histoire est vraie je vous jure
que c'est vrai on arrive
honnêtement 8 heures du matin la ja ont
fait taper un gars nous et nous on est
tous là et après jouer s'il vous plaît
le gars y répond pas il dit oui il ya
votre voiture vous avez oublié de
d'arrêter le
d'enlever la lumière là le gars sort
pour la lui faire d'abord là pour lui
pas là le gars il arrive il me voit et
on explique qu'il soit une gaffe et mais
moi je voulais je suis fou tout ça a
pris des proportions
mais l'histoire du tout cela n'appelle
pas et je lui dit il des cheminées
confrères j'appelle son frère et on lui
disait on à il appelle son frère de
didier at on peur de venir on attend son
plat pour voir si la même version
tu dis est là je son frère il arrivé
c'est quoi cette histoire je suis là les
mecs et c'était juste ça donc je me suis
retrouvé à 8 heures du matin à pourquoi
avoir des photos et on est reparti et je
peux vous dire dans le fourgon après je
suis bien passer pour un con
mais l'histoire est content quand même
ah bah oui mais c'est énorme mais quand
le mec a dit un et ça après des propos
vous êtes dingues ça donne cette année
comme un seul homme les honda mais c'est
pas c'est quoi
je me suis dis il vaut mieux qu'on sache
et qu'on repère où ils sont et où se
perd la trace et qu'on soit dans le bois
c'est qu'on dise ça peut voilà ça peut
attaquer à tout moment voilà l'histoire